do young actresses ever come to you and
say Gwen if you've done it all you've
won the Oscar you're what I want to be
do they ever seek your counsel about how
to how to be or how to act you know who
comes to me more are young female
entrepreneurs who are starting a digital
business because of goop's success
I spend a lot of time talk I have a few
women that I
talk to you Mentor types in a way yeah
um and I spend a lot more time with them
I I've never really had an actress call
me and say how do I do this would you
welcome something like that of course
yeah it's such a specific weird thing so
if I'm a young female entrepreneur which
I actually am uh how would I reach out
to you to get how would I reach out to
get to you so that I could get advice
usually it's through
um
I've met them in various ways sometimes
from speaking in a business school
sometimes from you do that I do you'll
show up at a business school I've done
it twice yeah Harvard yep no kidding
yeah and you're like hey you punks I
didn't go to business school and look
what I've done I wish I had gone to
business school there's so much I don't
know do they give you sometimes and
go well uh yeah you're advising us here
and you're giving a speech but you were
a famous actress so you got to skip a
step and then you set them straight and
say listen I still have to do the same
things you guys do geniuses right yeah
but you know they took accounting and I
didn't so they'll always have one up on
me that's got to be a trip to go to
Harvard Business what's turning you on
more the idea that you're a successful
entrepreneur
now with magazines books website the
whole deal
or or the acting thing
what feels like a better accomplishment
love
my role at goop and better than acting I
think I do better than winning an Oscar
look I'm so grateful for that whole
period of my life I mean it was
incredible and I think I'm able you know
I was able to start goop because I had
that platform as an actor
and I wouldn't change anything
and it was really weird for me to Pivot
and to kind of
essentially walk away from a film career
to do to try to be an entrepreneur and
you know I've learned so much it's been
so humbling and so fascinating and the
learning curve has been so Steep and
and I'm so proud of the team and what
we're doing and so I can't imagine
you know I I it almost gives me the same
feeling of exhilaration that you get
when you're on stage it's it's a similar
thing
foreign